welcome back to las vegas now have you
ever heard
of bro talks anybody in here bros
yep that is botox for men i caught up
with chicla v med spa to learn
what they're offering both men and women
as we welcome in swimsuit and pool
season take a look
being that it is approaching swimsuit
season here in las vegas i want to talk
a little bit about some of the body
contouring options that we offer here at
cheek living med spa
first of all we have coolsculpting
basically coolsculpting
is going in and freezing fat cells
thereby
giving us a more smooth result so
whether it's a little bit
of cellulite or just areas that aren't
quite getting reached by
working out at the gym and having a
healthy diet
coolsculpting can really fine-tune those
areas and freeze the fat
another option is m sculpt i myself have
tried it i absolutely love it
m sculpt is basically supercharging
what we can do in the gym for our abs it
can also be used
on the bottom as well i used it on my
abdominal area and after just one
session
i had visibly tighter and more defined
abdominal muscles another treatment
option that is actually on the
injectable side of the practice
is sculptra sculptra is a collagen
stimulating injectable it's not like a
traditional filler
using sculptra in the bottom not only
helps to enhance the shape and tone
but it's really targeting the problem at
base level we're rebuilding collagen
it's going to yield a more natural
result it's not going to give you
the bbl that a lot of patients are going
onto the plastic surgery side of the
practice for
because that's perfect that's a great
fit for that side but here we're doing a
more natural result
here at cheek v med spa just like many
med spas across the country we are
seeing
a shift in the male demographic there
has been a 59
increase in the male demographic at med
spas across the country
in the last five years so here i have
mario mario was in the early 50s
demographic
and i did botox on mario
botox is injected directly into the
muscle thereby weakening the muscle and
preventing
him from doing those dynamic movements
that cause the contractions
and over time those contractions are
what caused the fine lines and wrinkles
actually aaron did an amazing job and
she would inject me and she was done in
a matter of minutes so
went rather quickly this is not a long
procedure
in terms of time so this is something
that you can do
on your lunch time botox a lot of people
think it's more for women but in all
honesty you know i mean
we go to the gym we we work our bodies
there's no reason why you can't come and
see aaron actually do some
botox as well to my face so it makes me
feel better
here at chicla v we want you to feel and
look your best
even if you're a newbie and a first
timer and you're just dipping your toe
into the pool
of what the med spa has to offer we are
here to answer all of your questions i
have a team of professionals that i work
with both on the plastic surgery side
and here in the med spa
with my wonderful estheticians we will
help design
a treatment plan that suits your goals
that is safe effective and that makes
you feel and look your best
all right check out the chicla v med spa
on sahara boulevard for more information
just call 702-233-8535 or visit
[Music]
www.smithsurgery.com